Mango sticky rice is all I can think about,
and after ordering it and getting the tiniest portion,
I just decided to make it myself.
We buy a lot of mangoes when they're in season,
so I started off by making some mango ice cream.
I diced up my mango,
added them to a blender with some sweetener and lemon,
give that a good blend,
then combine some heavy cream,
milk, and some sugar.
Added my mango puree,
and let that chill in the fridge
before transferring it over to my ice cream Turner.
I turned it for about 20 to 30 minutes
until it reached a soft serve consistency,
and then I pop that in the freezer
while I got started on my sticky rice.
I had the rice soaking the night before and added it to my steamer.
I let that steam while I started on my coconut sauce
that was gonna go in with the rice,
which was coconut milk and some sweetener and a pinch of salt.
Once my rice was finished steaming,
I added my coconut milk to it,
covered it, and just let it sit while I made
thicker coconut sauce to go on top of the rice.
I let that reduce on the stove
while I finished up prepping all of my other things,
which was slicing some mango,
and by this time, my rice had soaked up all of that coconut milk,
so it was time to plate.
I put down my Rice,
added my mango,
added some of that coconut cream on top with some sesame seeds,
and then obviously had to pull out my mango ice cream.
The cold ice cream went perfectly with the warm rice.
This was absolutely divine.